Oh
I mean we talk about this all the time
the urge to create is like a knot in
your stomach finally out something you
have functional aesthetic out creates
something artful in the world all of a
sudden that anxieties God all of a
sudden that knot in your stomach
dissipates right instead you enter a
modality of cognitive ecstasy you enter
a exhilarating neuro storm as we were
talking about intense intellectual
pleasure a dopamine rush feeling of
doing a contribution and that's what
shots of awe is to all of us here you
holding the camera you know - Jordan -
Barry helping to produce - Tom you know
the crew of people that get together
here the band
we tried to like literally go out of our
minds in order to use our minds from the
first time right scramble the self to
transcend the ego to see what's up to
put it all out there right the transcend
is specific and only talk about the
universe for a second
leave the Trivium outdoor right that's
what we're doing that's what shots of
all is to share our ecstasy to share
subjectivity
to break through the screen to do what
we always hope technology would help us
do which is to come together
warp space and timing mmm that's what we
want to do
you